ck piscine
[Applaudissements]
dr c'est est-ce que tu pensais qu'à demi
tôt ce film et c'est terrible évidemment
il y avait une fausse piste s'était pas
sa silhouette avec la semaine dernière
n'est pas du tout la semaine c'était
vraiment philippe risoli alors capucines
là on s'est fait plaisir on voulait vous
voulez que tu sois là qu'a pu aussi ont
pu les missions sur les allées avec les
chutes et la hongrie il nous faut notre
copine i wanna be est une suite en fait
on précise parce que la vie est une
suite c'est un peu dramatique est là
aussi je peux pleurer très vite
non mais c'est vrai que c'est passer
plein de chose ne serait-ce que dans tpm
pee wee
exor divers est-ce que tu peux en
décrire certains un mail à l'émission se
termine dans une semaine si ces sites
tous les soirs il y avait foule à comme
ça voilà comme ça aille mal quand je
peux aider je peux aider parce que c'est
la jeune fille qui avait animé
brillamment un prime le pr ma capuche et
à la fin vous allez voir c'est un peu
emballé elle s'est dit que c'était une
bonne idée on en a parlé avec nicolas
avant d'ailleurs de lever les bras à la
fin de l'émission
pourquoi il faut jamais faire ça ses
petites copines spéciale qui devait
boire la haye vous devez voir vraiment
où le ratio n'est jamais de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible d'un groupe internet
fait un gros pigeon qui sait moins c'est
chez vous l'avez trouvé oui c'est moi
qui l'ait trouvée c'est mon père qui
combine des toiles sur le napperon
français oh [ __ ] va pas 5500 le
rapport
[Applaudissements]
m
souvenez que depuis que mathieu masseau
fait de mauvaise réponse je ne lui parle
plus mathieu alors déjà oui c'est quand
il vous dit donc des toiles sous drapeau
français oui est si fier aux yeux c'est
vrai que c'est quand même la honte
d'avoir dit çà oui avec leur attrait si
jamais transféré avec le stress était
persuadé que cyril allait me pose la
question combien d'étoilés hiatus sur le
drapeau européen dans tous les cas yona
12 donc dans tous les cas jouer ici est
élevé mais pour moi dans ma saison
oui j'avais l'image du drapeau européen
j'étais persuadé que c'était ça et
j'entends mathieu derrière et voilà donc
est-ce que c'est excusez moi la france
mais non non vous excusez pas grâce à
elle grâce à vous on a eu ce magnéto
ouais alors on vient sur les 1 10 de
seconde juste personne a confié alors
elle est figée théâtre le théâtre parce
que je veux jouer et j'ai joué au
théâtre vous avez joué au théâtre vous
actuellement aussi dans votre web série
qui cartonne en coloc way sur youtube
touché à 16 heures et ont un nouvel
épisode plus tous les toute la semaine
j'ai joué à côté d'eux eric laugerias
qui est un comédien de dingue de toi
quand vous dites j'ai joué à côté avec
plutôt parce que jouer sa scène de l'
elysée
et puis vous avez des guests chaque
année à chaque saison
chaque semaine oui j'ai eu camille
combal et mac etc qui est une très
grosse oeil que tu buzz
eric laugerias des dégâts kelly fait
partie de l'équipe 2 du sperme passant
voilà quoi c'était trop cool et on vous
a vu aussi dans une série sur
enfin exactement qui s'est achevée hier
il ya deux semaines j'ai vu un épisode
encore il ya un mois oui oui mais moi
j'étais ya quinze jours
oui mais je regarde aussi les autres
puisque vous avez dans money ouais avec
l'excellente isabelle nanty sur jean
baptiste en fait une grosse grosse
actualité et là il ya des projets oui on
a un petit peu d'accord bas montchamp et
avons une part de mystère